in just seven years time it's hope
there'll be enough wind farms to power
every single home in the UK so why are
some wind generators being paid to turn
off when it's too windy here's what you
need to know
[Music]
last year nearly a quarter of the UK's
total electricity production came from
wind power and depending on the day it
can actually be quite a lot more than
that when it's very windy actually wind
can provide more than half of the UK's
electricity
when it's very windy sometimes we have a
problem because we generate a lot of the
electricity in the north of the country
in Scotland and in the North Sea
obviously because it's very windy but a
lot of the demand for electricity
remains in the south of the country
around London in particular so we have
to move that electricity from the north
to the South and our issue is that when
it's extremely windy actually wind farms
produce too much electricity for the
cables that we have right now there's a
real bottleneck between the Scottish
transmission system and the English
transmission system and because we don't
have the capacity to store excess
renewable energy when we make it not yet
anyway the National Grid electricity
system operator has no choice but to ask
the wind farms to turn off and then
those wind farms get paid for doing so
in addition the National Grid then has
to turn on gas power stations closer to
the source of demand nearby London for
example
this is happening more and more as we
add more and more wind power onto the
system and our capacity to generate
electricity using wind continues to
outstrip the capacity of our
transmission system so last year it cost
about 200 million pounds to turn off
wind power and by one calculation around
700 million pounds to turn on gas power
close to the source of demand and the
National Grid has estimated that the
problem will probably get worse these
constraint costs are going to increase
towards the middle of this decade
possibly up to as high as 2.5 billion
pounds a year and the cost of all of
this is ultimately born by Bill payers
the National Grid makes the first
payment but then passes on those costs
and we all pay for them under the
network cost section of our electricity
bills
thank you
now constraint costs aren't just limited
to wind the National Grid pays to
balance the system it pays fossil fuel
generators to ramp down production as
well but there's a big focus on the
issues around transmitting renewable
energy because of such an important part
of our future such an important part of
the government's promise to completely
decarbonize power generation by 2035. so
what are the solutions well because
everyone knows it's a problem of gem the
government the National Grid they are
very focused on solving it there are
plans underway already to build an
expensive new undersea cable between
Scotland and England that's going to
cost over 3 billion pounds and take
about five years to complete and there's
lots of investment going into storage
Technologies like green hydrogen and
batteries and pumped Hydro but the
bottom line is the transmission capacity
issue in the UK has to be sold if we are
to get to Net Zero by 2050 and to
decarbonize our power system items by
2035.